there are a number of conspiracy
theories around the events of 9 11. do
any of these hold true to you
or do they just frustrate you even anger
you
been asked this
by a few different people in my life
this is my take on it right you're a man
of science and a man of education so you
allegedly allegedly but yes but you you
know you're a very very intelligent man
and
what i believe took place is this
a structural steel
will fail
at
a sustained temperature of 1500 degrees
fahrenheit and i don't know exactly how
long that would have to be sustained
but that's the temp right
diesel fuel kerosene fuel
kerosene based jet fuel which
was the ignition there
burns at 2200 degrees fahrenheit
so
that
continued burning of that diesel that
jet fuel but kerosene based you know
it's all kind of similar
exceeded the temperature needed for that
steel in the structural members of the
trade center to fail
in my heart of hearts i would hate to
ever think that somebody
affiliated with our government with some
sort of agenda
would perpetrate that crime and that
tragic just
destruction of humanity and property
for some other form of gain
those planes rammed into those buildings
at 450 miles an hour
they were loaded with thousands and
thousands of gallons of jet fuel
number seven trade center had the backup
for the emergency management sys system
for the city
and there was an emergency generator in
that complex which had a 25 000 gallon
tank of diesel fuel to continually run
for weeks to keep the
911 system the backup system going in
the case of a catastrophic event
well that tank in seven heated up from
the fire that was already going on from
the aircraft debris coming into the
building so once that diesel
became ignited in seven
now you had
enough temperature to fail that steel in
that building
so
i would like to truly believe what i've
learned from the minimal fire science
knowledge i have from my career
that it was just a matter of
it burned too long it burned too hot and
it failed
i mean if you look at the way it came
down
it came down as it was designed to
in the god-forbid event that it was to
collapse it it came down pancaking upon
itself
if it had failed horizontally and just
sprayed out side to side
those buildings would have dropped for a
quarter half a mile up to canal street
but you know like and the destruction
oh my gosh it could have been so much
worse i mean it you would have taken out
every building you know
from that
point all the way up
but in my heart i'd like to just believe
that it was just a fire that burned too
long and too hot you know these these
planes cause structural damage upon
impact in both buildings
and it was just a matter of time and
then you think about it you add all the
plastics all the carpeting
all of the stuff that was burning on
those floors you add that to that fire
load
i think it just had enough to collapse
it
and you were in uh building seven for
part of that day i was just after it
came down as well we were excited and we
weren't in it or next to it when it
actually did come down
but moments after we were there and
again i i would like to believe that it
just
it was just that that fuel was going and
it just took its physics took its course
and it failed
so physics and science aside its heart
uh it's both i would like to believe and
it's hard to imagine that anybody would
be so evil as to orchestrate parts of
this
from within the united states government
that's very difficult for me to imagine
yeah you know what though lex there's
people and i and i won't elaborate i
won't get into it any any any
controversial subjects but what have you
there's some people that don't have any
problem at all perpetrating any level of
evil
people like you and i who have hearts
and we have depth of soul
we couldn't imagine it but there's other
people wouldn't even be a second thought
i mean they've seen i've seen some
horrific incidents in my career
that i go home shaking my head at night
going
human beings are just they're not wired
right
you know i mean i look at animals i love
animals i love dogs especially right and
i i see this dog park when
i uh i train to fly airplanes now and
something i wanted to do
and there's a dog park across from the
airport and there's 60 dogs
and there's bones flying up in the air
and chewed toys and sticks and they're
running around having the time of their
life right
and they're all getting along
and they're not hurting each other
they're not violating each other they're
not
canceling each other that and and i'm
going we really need to learn from these
dogs like right and like
i just yeah i mean sometimes it sounds
crazy but i think they're better they're
a better species than people
unless they're rabid they don't hurt on
purpose they don't you know they don't
cut you off in traffic and throw you the
middle finger and you know just these
they just don't do these
these acts of
humanity that sometimes are so vicious
why do you think these conspiracy
theories
of which there's a lot
uh take hold
why why do you think so many people
believe some version of different
conspiracy theories around 9 11.
well you know like many things in life
it leaves me a little conflicted i i
have to say this i am at the point now i
don't know who to believe anymore
so
i could see that
lending a hand to someone who's already
a doubter going oh yeah look that
exactly that's what they're doing right
i mean you know look at this whole virus
like
who do you believe like where'd it come
from uh you know like and and and you
know if you plant that seed
it's like that little campfire we were
talking about earlier right you just
toss a little gas into those embers you
got a fire now i also think there's a
lot of people with a hell of a lot of
extra time on their hands right and
they're really bored you know the two
are combined alex yeah man you know like
look i was a three job charlie right you
know one guy used to say to me you know
anything but but home i go no i i got
deadlines responsibilities you know
like that's that's what it comes down to
is like
i mean look we all we all have our
hobbies and things we like and you know
little nuances and that's what makes us
special we're unique every person is a
unique being
but
i also think some people just just they
want to cling to something
like we all want to feel accepted and
belong to something so
all of a sudden you you group up with
these people and you all believe this
fervently like yeah yeah you know they
did it they took it down they took it
down and and now you start going
yeah and and i think what happens is
when you're in company of people and you
start telling each other the same thing
often you freaking believe it i mean if
you keep telling me i got a great head
of hair i'm going to go you know what i
do but no i don't i mean right i got
that waving bye bye dude but like but
you know i think when you start hearing
something often you stop believing it
but i'm not gonna i'm not gonna doubt
their intelligence i'm not gonna doubt
their intentions but
i just don't see it as being plausible i
just i
it would be too
too big of an operation to to
successfully happen
you